Paula Reid is at the White House with a
presidential fact-check Paula good
morning good morning there is an
overwhelming consensus among US
intelligence and law enforcement that
Russia orchestrated a campaign to
interfere in the 2016 US presidential
election but president Trump has been
reluctant to accept that conclusion or
the evidence that supports it and that
makes him a solitary figure in his
administration at his party they said
they think it's Russia
I have President Putin he just said it's
not Russia I will say this I don't see
any reason why it would be president
Trump appeared to side with Vladimir
Putin over his own intelligence agencies
Monday President Putin was extremely
strong and powerful in his denial today
those comments drew a strong rebuke from
his own Director of National
Intelligence dan coates who said in a
statement we have been clear in our
assessments of Russian meddling in the
2016 election and their ongoing
pervasive efforts to undermine our
democracy u.s. intelligence agencies and
the Justice Department as well as
bipartisan committees in the House and
Senate have all endorsed the assessment
that Russians launched a covert
operation to sway the u.s. election the
indictment charges 12 Russian military
officers by name just last week Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosen Stein
announced new charges filed by special
counsel robert muller directly linking
the operatives to the russian government
the indictment includes 11 criminal
allegations and in February Muller
charged 13 Russians and three Russian
companies for running a troll farm to
meddle in the election Rosen Stein
briefed the president about the
allegations days before he left for the
summit with Putin making these comments
regarding and offered by Putin all the
more surprising
he offered to have the people working on
the case come and work with their
investigators with respect to the 12
people I think that's an incredible
offer the special counsels office
declined to comment on that offer but
they did point to two cases where they
have sought Russia's help in pursuing
cyber criminals Russia declined to
cooperate in both instances
Gail all right Paula thank you